Hi, welcome back.
In the first session on arbitrage, I
talked about the promise of arbitrage,
the fact that you can take no risk,
invest no money, and walk away with a
sure profit. That's alluring, right? And
not surprisingly, people trying to sell
investment strategies have discovered
that calling it arbitrage makes it more
sellable.
In this session, I want to talk about
what I call pseudo or speculative
arbitrage, which is really not arbitrage
at all. It's just a risky investment
strategy. It doesn't have to be a bad
one. It could be a good one. But the
word arbitrage here doesn't fit because
these strategies actually expose their
investors to lots of risk. So, you're
saying, "Why would people use the word
arbitrage to describe them?" As I
mentioned,
it's because the people selling these
strategies have either deluded
themselves into believing these
strategies are riskless, or they've they
want to delude others into believing
they're riskless. The truth is, these
are risky strategies. Sooner the people
using these strategies accept that, the
healthier their investing will be in
this space.
So, let's look at some examples.
The first is what's called paired
arbitrage.
Some of you might have read about
Long-Term Capital Management. This is a
This is an entity that was created in
the 1990s with stellar credentials. John
Meriwether came from Salomon, where he
built this great fixed income business,
and he brought in, you know, two Nobel
Prize winners, and Bob Merton, and Myron
Scholes, and created Long-Term Capital
Management. The promise was, "We have
the smartest people in finance in our
midst, and we're going to find sure
profits to make."
One of the strategies that they adopted
to kind of to allow for the fact that
they were growing, and a lot of money
was coming in, was paired arbitrage.
You're saying, "What's paired
arbitrage?"
You take two stocks that have
historically moved together.
Let's take an example that in the US in
the 20th century had resonance.
GM and Ford, the two largest automobile
companies in the US for much of the 20th
century.
And over much of the 20th century, they
moved in a in a way that was fairly
predictable. GM traded at a higher PE
ratio than Ford and lots of good reasons
were given.
But they had a ratio of prices that
stayed pretty stable over time. So
here's how paired arbitrage works.
You have two stocks that have moved,
let's say in a two to one ratio for the
last so GM trades at twice Ford and it's
done it for the last 50 years.
If GM trades at two and a half times
Ford today, you argue that GM is
overvalued relative to Ford and you
carry through. You buy Ford, you sell GM
and you hope for convergence.
You can already see paired arbitrage is
ultimately built on mean reversion.
Not just in one stock, but in two stocks
moving together. And historically, the
conventional practice is to look at
stocks that are in the same business
that have been tied together
and look at the data to see what that
pattern is.
Already, you can see that paired
arbitrage
is not a riskless strategy. It has
worked on average so studies suggest
that it works.
But the returns you make are relatively
small. Okay? They in fact, in a one
study looked at finding a magic partner
for each stock just based in the data by
looking at how they move together. They
paired the stocks with the smallest at
the highest correlation with each other.
And over a 15-year period, this strategy
seemed to earn significant returns, an
excess return of about 6%. Again, not
mind-blowing, but well, you know, that's
still it's you're not going to sneeze at
it. That's a pretty good excess return.
And so at least on paper, it looked like
paired stocks strategies work.
So what can go wrong?
First is
it is not a riskless strategy. It's
risky because you're building it on mean
reversion and history repeating itself,
and history doesn't always repeat
itself. In fact, staying with a
long-term capital management story,
long-term capital management blew up
partly because their paired stocks
strategy blew up. Things that they
thought would move together stopped
moving together.
And as as people you know, jumped onto
the bandwagon and tried the same
strategy, trying the it's the profit
seemed to wear off. So, very quickly,
you know, the excess returns you saw
start to wear off over time.
So, paired stock stocks strategy taking
two companies that have historically
moved together in a ratio that has been
predictable,
and you've tried to take advantage of it
when that when the actual ratio deviates
from that predictable ratio. But, you're
built on mean reversion, and that stops
working, you're going to lose money.
Let's move on to merger arbitrage.
Again, a massive misuse of the word
arbitrage. What's merger arbitrage?
Earlier in the session, we looked at
what happens around acquisitions, right?
There's a target company, there's an
acquiring company. The acquiring company
comes in and makes its acquisition bid,
and the target company stock price jumps
on the announcement. But, it turns out
it doesn't jump all the way up to the
price that the acquiring company is
offering. So, when an acquiring company
offers a $50 price, the target company
will often go to 46 or 47, not all the
way to 50. Why? Because there's a chance
that the merger might not work, and
investors hold back.
Merger arbitrage is built on that fact.
That there's a drift between what
happens right after the announcement and
the eventual price. You're still making
a bet that the merger will succeed. And
if you're good about picking the mergers
that you know are going to succeed, then
you will make money as the stock goes
from 47 to 50, the target company's
stock price.
In a more sophisticated variant where
you have share exchanges, where you have
the acquiring company and the target
company shares come into play because
two shares of the acquiring company
going to go pay for a share, merger
arbitrage, you might buy shares in both
companies and try to take advantage of
the combined value going up
as the uncertainty about the merger
disappears. But ultimately, merger
arbitrage is a bet on mergers being
consummated.
Again, if you look at studies,
one study looked at 4,750 mergers and
concluded that merger arbitrage
generated returns. So basically, on
these mergers, they looked at what would
happen if you bought the target company
at the the price right right after the
acquisition announcement and waited and
collected. They said, "Even allowing for
failures, you make a 9.25% return over
and above what you need to."
But if you bring in the effect of
transactions causing the price impact,
you have about 2/3 of those returns
disappear. So it's a pretty modest
excess return.
But here's the bigger problem. When
there's a failure, a merger falls apart,
and some mergers do,
these strategies create very large
negative returns.
That's something you're going to notice
with all of these speculative arbitrage
strategies. They work most of the time,
but when they fail, they have big
negative payoffs. The reason that's
relevant is you can do a study of these
strategies and they might work and work
and work, and over the 5 years you
looked at them, they earned great
returns.
But the sixth year, that catastrophic
event happens and wipes out all of the
money you made over the 5 years.
So if you look at success at speculative
arbitrage, one of the keys, I think, is
to be careful about how much debt to
use.
If you remember pure arbitrage, you
borrowed all of the money you needed to
buy
buy something. Why? Because there's no
risk. It doesn't matter that you borrow
100% whether it's a futures arbitrage or
an
or replicating option arbitrage.
Borrowing is riskless because you
created a riskless strategy. If you
create a risky strategy,
you might not be able to borrow 100%,
90%. We might not be able to borrow any
money if it's a risky enough strategy.
One of the reasons again Long-Term
Capital Management failed was not just
that fair paired
no fair trading didn't work, but that
they borrowed way too much money to fund
a strategy as risky as pair trading.
So, when it gets to near and speculative
arbitrage, I think you have to adjust
your leverage.
And to make money, you got to make sure
you don't have a market impact as you do
all of this. So, when you try to go out
there and in the process of trying to
take advantage of a mispricing, you push
up the price of whatever you're trying
to buy or push down the price of
whatever you're trying to sell. You can
very quickly wipe out the profits you
make. So, this might be a philosophy
that works better for a small fund,
somebody with a limited amount of
capital. It might not work as you scale
up. And again, going back to Long-Term
Capital Management, one reason I think
they failed is they got too big.
And once you get bigger, you start to
have a market impact and that very
quickly can wipe out your profits.
Now, to complete this process of
arbitrage, even though it doesn't quite
fit, I'm going to bring in hedge funds.
What can hedge funds do that traditional
mutual funds cannot?
I think the biggest difference, and if
you're truly a hedge fund, you should be
exploiting this difference, is you can
both go long, buy, and sell short.
Traditional mutual funds can't sell
short. So, to the extent that you can go
long and sell short, hedge funds at
least have the the
of creating positions
that if not riskless are very low risk
because you're both long and short in
investments.
And within hedge funds you have a huge
range of hedge funds. Some bet on macro
events, some bet on micro, some do value
growth. So you can take every single
investment philosophy we've talked about
so far in this class and create a hedge
fund around it.
So let's look at hedge funds
and the early promise that drives so
much of why people hold them in such
high regard. Early in the process, hedge
funds and hedge funds are not new to the
market. They've come and gone and
there's some lessons in history from why
they've gone.
I mean hedge funds exist in the early
part of the 1900s but then you know big
collapses and then they went away, they
came back again.
And in their most least recent iteration
at least early on it looked like hedge
funds were delivering a payoff. And what
were not because they earned higher
returns than traditional mutual funds
but because of the risk return trade-off
that they delivered which was better
than the risk and return you would make
by just investing your money in stocks.
So for instance, if you look at this
study of hedge funds in their early
years, the average return you earned on
hedge funds was only 13.26%
you think what do you mean only 13.26%?
That was actually lower than somebody
put their money in the S&P 500. Saying
why would I then invest in hedge funds?
Because it turns out that while the
return was lower, they also had a much
lower standard deviation in returns than
the S&P 500. Remember we talked about
Sharpe ratios? You take the return and
divide by the standard deviation. If you
compute the Sharpe ratios for hedge
funds, 13.26 / 9.07, that's a much
better Sharpe ratio than what you get
for the S&P 500.
That's always been the sales pitch for
hedge funds. Not that they deliver
higher absolute returns but that they
deliver much better trade-offs in terms
of return and risk.
The catch though is
hedge funds also have astoundingly high
costs. Many hedge funds follow what's
called the two and 20, which means they
take 2% of your money every year and 20%
of the upside.
If you bring in those fees and costs,
it's not clear even these big payoffs
last, but that's something to factor in.
Now, if you look across categories that
return risk trade-off, you know,
the gross return net returns vary across
categories, but what they all share in
common is a sales pitch, which is we can
get you these returns with much lower
risk than going into a long only
strategy.
Now, let's look at hedge funds a little
closer to see what it is you might have
to worry about if you're an investor
thinking about putting your money in
hedge funds. It's true. They offer much
better risk return risk trade-offs, and
this has been pretty much the case in
every study of hedge funds.
But there's a significant survival risk
that if you don't factor in, will bias
you towards finding hedge funds to be
better investors than they truly are.
What am I talking about? A bad mutual
fund can stay bad and not go away. A bad
hedge fund
goes away. The way this shows up in
studies, if I look at existing hedge
funds and work backwards, I will
overstate the returns of hedge funds.
Why? Cuz to see what hedge funds made
over the last 5 years, I need to go back
in time 5 years ago, put my money in
hedge funds as they existed then, and
allow for the fact that hedge funds that
die are the ones where I will lose the
most money. This is survival issue with
hedge funds.
And if you factor in that survival
issue, and the fact that hedge funds
have become so much bigger in terms of
money they invest,
a reality check is coming into play.
Remember we talked about alphas, what
you earn over and above.
Even allowing for the fact that hedge
funds might deliver less risk than
traditional funds, and you calculate the
alpha based on that lower risk,
the alphas of hedge funds have been on a
downward trend for a long time.
In fact, for the last decade, you cannot
reject the hypothesis that the alphas of
hedge funds have dropped to zero.
You say, "Why is this happening?" Again,
imitation. Lots of capital coming in is
wiping out the excess returns with hedge
funds. If you remember, we discovered
the same phenomenon with private equity.
Two of the pillars of alternative
investing have seen their alphas
decrease over time because of more money
coming in.
So, let's summarize what we've learned
with arbitrage.
Arbitrage can take three forms. It can
be pure arbitrage, where you have two
assets exactly the same cash flows
trading at different prices. They can
borrow 100%, lock in the profit, you
have pure arbitrage profits. That's
great, but it's rare, and it doesn't
last very long.
Near arbitrage is more common,
but near arbitrage comes with some risk,
and you got to adjust for that when you
borrow money.
And there can be that some risk, and
sometimes blow up on you. And pseudo
arbitrage is really not arbitrage. I
don't even know why we attach the term
arbitrage for it.
It's just risky strategies. They might
be good risky strategies. They might
deliver returns that justify the risk,
but arbitrage doesn't belong in here.
Hedge funds, in theory, could do
arbitrage, but in practice, they don't.
They have lower risk strategies coming
from the fact that they can sell short.
And at least, over time, we've
discovered their alphas have decreased
as they become bigger, and become more
difficult for you to create excess
returns.
So, I hope you found this session
useful, and I thank you very much for
listening.